hi I'm going to be guiding you through
the coding portions of this course
you're going to start out by deploying a
very simple App Engine application but
users endpoints to expose this API to
clients then you're going to learn how
to define endpoint functions and how to
call them from a webpage using
javascript and the Google JavaScript
client library then you learn about the
Google API Explorer which is a really
cool tool not only lets to explore the
Google public API it lets you test out
the API in your own application as you
work through this course you're going to
be building up an application called
conference central which let's use a
schedule and query for conferences and
you're going to be focusing on
implementing the backend functionality
just like on a cooking show where they
bake the cake for you ahead of time and
take it out of the oven ready baked
we've written some of the code for you
particularly the boilerplate code so
that you can get straight to work
writing the code that really matters
you're going to start out by downloading
the starting version of conference
central for this lesson and building it
up as you go from lesson to lesson but
at any point if you don't complete the
exercises you don't need to worry
because we provide starting code for you
to help you out every stage along the
way come on then let's go write some
code